[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everybody
welcome to another episode of the
technically brilliant show
which is a co-production of denton black
film festival
and black pulpit media today our guest
is
fabiano mishu a filmmaker and artist
who lives and works in brazil let's
bring on fabiano
hi lisa thanks for having me today oh
our pleasure um nice to see you i know
you were
recently on a break so welcome back to
civilization
um so today we're just going to talk
about um your background and training
and then we're going to move into a
conversation about your current project
which is monica puru vr
which was the teaser that we just gave
people
showed people about the project so first
up
um when did you first start developing
an interest in technology
and when you were in high school like
you know did they offer classes at the
high school level or did they have clubs
or anything like that
no actually no i didn't have
any any tech school
at this time i first was
really interested in art so i went to
the art school
but when i went there i realized that
the
people and professors
thought my work were more film
oriented than than art okay
then i started studying film and
the people i realized that people
have had the same impression uh but
in the opposite way so they told me your
work is more
artists than the film so so did this
did that start happening from high
school or it only happened once you went
to college
no after uh after high school okay
got it for film and arts and everything
got it so i'm in between
and i love this position to be honest uh
i like art and
and and film uh mostly and
that brought me to new technologies like
uh xr vitoria reality
augmented reality and so on right
do you remember when you first saw a
virtual reality experience like was that
back in high school or was it in college
no that was in berlin in 2012
if i'm if i'm sure it was in in the
billionaire film festival
and um it was a really
small uh
uh opening show uh for vr
these days uh it was not it were not
not uh so right what what caught your
like why did it you know capture your
attention
yeah for me it was the eyes the looking
the gaze
uh when i first saw
someone starting at me
actually at the camera but it felt like
the gaze was to me it was really intense
and uh something happened to me and
i i first realized the potential of the
medium
and and also what what could be
developed
uh in in storytelling right
so did that what were you doing in
berlin in 2012
oh yeah i studied film there i went to
berlin in 2010
to graduate in a film school
okay directing uh there
for four years or more of that got it
got it so you were so but while you were
in grad school how long was your grad
school it was from 2010 to 2014 is that
what you're saying
yeah i first started studying in
film uh art in a famous art school i got
a fellowship there
and then i went to the university in the
eu
and filmed university but it it was for
me
to academic and and i
i i i was more uh
convinced to to to reality to make works
and i went to berlin and i
i got this this uh
school which is a self-organizated
school
uh in berlin where we could uh
approach many experiments and and and
technical aspects of human got it
so are you saying that you went to two
different grad schools like you started
at one and then you changed your mind
and went to a different one
i started in michigan and finished in
berlin
okay you started where berlin
no where was the first place that you
started was it a different city from
berlin
it was in huge general it was in the
book university
oh you started art school in in brio and
then went to berlin to go to the
experimental film school
exactly okay got it i just wanted to yes
for your fbi files sorry
to put it in there um all right so
once you now have both undergraduate
degree and film and now a graduate
degree in film from an experimental
program
what did you what was your vision at
that point in terms of what you wanted
to do with your career
i it's something i i discovered
by the time just doing my work and
but my work is very historical oriented
doesn't matter if i make film or art it
has
always historical aspects inside uh
and this process uh really really got me
uh to work
that is what what brings me
forward and um that is
what if what i feel if i think uh
being uh to be between those
those uh uh forms
filament yeah like the hybrid forms very
much
and you like hybrid okay well why don't
we why don't you tell us what monaco
peru vr is about and then we'll watch
your pitch video from april at the bpm
plus showcase
yeah it's a
collective art making experience uh
which invites users to destroy
images or historical images of brazil
from brazil and the idea is that the
people
are going to discover that collective
so the hope is
just a way to get the people
and that interaction uh with
historical uh aspects of brazil
colonialism
and and so on okay why don't we take a
look at the pitch video
yes god just i forgot i have to hit
share share
no oops nope share screen
sure all right tab
fantastic okay
is a daring experiment in the making of
collective art
it invites users to destroy images from
brazil's history in an experience that
is part of physical art installation
part of the apology the intention of
this experience
is to invite the further tone culver
centuries of brazilian history
encapsulated in seven images
seven layers each one hides in the next
images that are never totally seen or
totally uncovered and that
overlap others like the effect that the
passing of time has our lives and
memories
[Music]
kanakapuru vr starts in a real world
gallery with a big wall
this wall is covered by a big sheet of
paper river wrapping it
behind this paper there are seven other
layers each branch has a different
pattern
reality and translated into images when
users have their headsets on
when the public arrives in the gallery
you'll see the blank paper wall
with the vr headset on they will see the
same wall
and they will be invited to discover
what is behind the loop
by tearing it down and revealing what
lies beneath
the vr version of the wall saves the
actions of each user
so that the next person may pick up
where the previous one laptop
the end of one user's experience becomes
the beginning of the next user as a
starting point
each user will have seven minutes of
experience
if a user decides to tear a lot of it
down the lens will be left for those who
follow them
and the knowledge of the limited natural
resources that we use recklessly
by tearing down the paper the username
is a wall of interactive audiovisual
fragments that we are calling memories
memories over the foundation and
development of brazilian society
brazil's most important economic cycles
in the past
should became gold mines coffee and
nowadays
soybeans were based in the exploitation
of nature and people
users would discover images of a
permanent forest a mineral collapsing
newspaper defines selling black people
striking images that have built
positional power over
all centuries from the country's huge
african diaspora to its present day
from climate capacity to to search of
old-fashioned european classes
being the goal of the internet culture
this memory is meant to be the
nightmares of a nation whose presence is
a result of slavery
and whose economic specific
environmental destruction and people
exploitation has progressed
manakapuru vr's final piece of art will
be the product of how people interact
with memories with destruction and
recreation it's unique and
unpredictable
a black public media grant enabled
monaco
to complete an initial research and
project definition phase
between october 2020 and april 2021.
now we need resources to go to a
research and development
phase focused on tech testing and to
start production
research and development will take three
months and cost forty three thousand
dollars
production will take nine months and
cost three hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars
mana capri vr needs a total budget of
three hundred and sixty thousand dollars
and twelve months to be created
becomes the nightstand of creation much
like the formation of brazil itself
what does it mean to destroy a country
and what does it take
to build one
great i haven't watched that in full
since
in a while um it's a really good pitch
video i thought your team did a really
excellent job on it um so which
headsets will that experience work on
we are going to work with oculus quest
and the project going to be developed in
unity
got it um and so
are you a coder yourself no no i'm not
called
unfortunately we are working with other
people to gathering collaborators
and making some experiments with paper
as well so the analogic side of the work
has been improved as well
but we are we are seeking for uh
support and to continue developing this
work
got it so what kind of developers do you
need aside from unity do you is there a
specific language that you're using
or just unity yeah for now
we we are working with unity and
it's c
[Music]
c sharp yes yes
okay all right cool um and so can you
read code are you like code literate
like can you actually proof code
yourself or see what it's doing or you
are
you know what where is your where does
the border light
lie for you in terms of building your
projects yeah
that is something i miss to be honest as
an artist
working with technologists i think i
should
have abilities to code but it's also
amazing to work with collaborators it's
like
when i am a director and working and be
working with
a writer so the the project become
becomes more
has more uh perspectives and it
could be more rich so uh got it
why don't you describe to me so if i see
the monica puru booth at a film festival
or at a museum
talk talk me through the experience i
walk into the booth what happens next
so uh the first uh you are going to see
the wall a wall uh and the public
and the audience will be invited to
uncover this
[Music]
seven layers of paper and which
one is behind the next and it each one
represents an image
or historical image of brazil so you are
going to have
seven minutes about seven minutes uh to
rip
part of of of this paper down
and that is a unique
experience because the next one are
going to see what you
left behind okay at what point do i put
the headset on when i first walk into
the booth and i see the paper
yeah what yes that's a part of a
physical installation in part of viacola
[Music]
we have both uh
to be experienced there so we are going
to
really rip down with your hands
the paper the physical physical paper
okay
okay but uh in the glasses in the
virtual reality glass
you are going to see what exactly what
this paper represents
as an image okay got it so basically i
have
i'm seeing something you've designed
inside the headset but at the same time
it doesn't block me from seeing the real
world is still visible through the
headset
exactly each okay in victoria reality
and he presents a
part as aspect historical aspect of
brazil
okay so it's really a mixed reality
piece not so much a pure
virtual reality piece
to see that as a node this work
is works for me like a node
between the virtual world world and the
physical world
got it a node between the virtual world
and the physical world i like that
so what is the next phase of the project
in the video it said something about
doing
um more research and development and
moving into production
what describe to us what you'd like to
accomplish during that phase
yes exactly we have we still working on
research process because yes uh
it's is a part of the history we lost
so we have some challenge to find these
pictures and
to find this this images uh
but we are moving now uh to the first
experiment
uh with with the paper uh the analogy on
a logic part
and we are seeking for support to go to
development process
to really go deep in in the in the
process
of programming and development got it
um how long do you think that sort of
pre-production phase
will last pre-production phase is
about three months okay
totally we have 12 months production
to have the piece ready
got it got it so what advice would you
give
um to other filmmakers and especially
traditional visual artists you know like
painters
and you know sculptors who want to
actually start to use
technologies like virtual reality or
augmented reality to tell stories what
advice would you have for them
i would say something like you
break the frame you have to break the
frame
and go deep in this new victoria reality
world
and just just
follow your instincts and your
your um intimate uh
projects that's that's okay and where do
you recommend that people start to
expose themselves you know to vr and ar
like where are the some places for them
to discover
other pieces we have a lot of
films and works in youtube
available for free but we have also
especially independent pandemic times
a bunch of festivals uh opening
uh the screams and the programs online
so
uh look look it out and maybe
you can find tribal sundance film
festivals
program available it's got it
so what do you um what would
has your vision for the project changed
since you pitched it at the bpm plus
showcase in april
like is there anything that you are
thinking you want to add to the project
or explore with the project
you know in coming months yes um
it's still uh under on the
process but i have been also um
adding um
ar technologies uh oh okay this project
uh so uh we are thinking about a version
of uh mana kapoor in a uh
okay that would be exciting i cannot
talk a lot
a lot totally just one you know it's
been a couple of months
so that's why i just wanted to do a
check-in and um
are you working on any other projects
aren't you working on another ar project
yes exactly i'm in the i'm the fellow
black public media
and mit doculated fellow
and i have been developing mesh memories
which is an
augmented reality portrait of mumbai
atta
maja and we are
in the last uh in the last uh uh
weeks of work i hope in a month we'll
have it ready
oh wow okay when did you start to work
on it
i started in january uh working
on it and uh together so it's been six
months
six months yeah how did the while you
were doing the fellowship did the vision
for the mother biata piece change at all
oh a lot we have been uh experimenting
with
a lot of uh we have a lot of versions of
the work
but especially because again we don't
have a
really big archive we have just some
photos it's difficult to work with
but we are getting there where
we are happy and got it
are you just using still photographs for
that ar piece or are you also using
video
just still photographs okay
and what are you um which ar platform
are you using or is are you having your
developer custom code something for you
yeah we are going to uh exhibit the work
in qr codes okay
here we don't want to create a
app a separate app we would like to
put it so so uh
public or so open as possible and
[Music]
yeah i forgot the question uh
i was asking you um what platforms you
were going to use or are you having your
developer custom code a solution
for niche memories yes that's that's the
point
okay we are going to create pre-accounts
and exhibited
in public spaces the idea is
a kind of a boost uh
virtual virtual uh boost of maybe other
germans
in public okay where
so what with this ar bust do you already
have a site
is it going to be tied to a specific
geographic location like coordinates or
will it be something that i can pull up
on my phone here from atlanta
yeah if you have uh it's a
site specific because we need uh
yeah uh the kiako to access that i don't
want to put it
online the the place has a meaning
but okay i'm also planning to have uh
the first one and maybe the main uh
site specific in her temple and the
germans so the people could also ask us
uh aspect of her in
art form okay and who was mother biata
why are you focusing on her for this uh
this ar sculptor
my battery a religion
african brazilian religions lead leader
a writer
and activist in brazil it's a
very famous figure in
the community and who also
uh strong activists for women's rights
and and
and elegibility rights and and so on
and who my main interest for her
is how she um
got to maintain the african culture
orally
that's that's my main
interest is she she was a proponent of
a strong proponent of um the oral
tradition
you're saying in terms of african
teachings and
um cultural traditions and things like
that
yes because the religions african
religions uh
really got the culture alive
and and keep going orally so
it is maybe the closed the closed
way to assess that that old culture
we somehow lost in the colony
time so you got it
so what size will the ar sculpture be
when i access it with a qr code
is it typically you know when you have a
public bust it can be anywhere from
you know a bust is normally sometimes
two feet tall or a foot and a half tall
and then you know but with ar you can do
whatever you want so what size are you
and the developer planning to make it um
display
we are thinking about a real size not so
big or not so small
like like real boosts
in everyday uh uh live
public spaces so it's maybe a little bit
uh bigger than usual uh used to be
our head okay so you're not going for
something that's a spectacle
or monumental scale
i i want to create some intimacy
between the peace and i don't want to
get so big and you know it's something
we have
approached with some intimacy okay
with some intimacy okay got it well
fabiano thank you so much for joining us
on the show today
um i wish you the best of luck in terms
of finding funding for the next phase of
monica puru vr
and um and good luck finishing um
development on mesh memories your ar
sculpture
in the next month i hope you're able to
finish it by the end of august as you
plan
or the beginning of august as you plan
um
and thank you so much for joining us on
the show today
thank you thank you for having me lisa
my pleasure um well thank you everybody
for joining us today
um see you next week our guest will be
tamara sagalu
a filmmaker and artist who's based in
amsterdam
and divides her time with la as well she
runs a production company called adawato
pictures
and we'll be discussing her most recent
project the ar memorial
unresolved see you next week thank you